gqueues best new menswear designer award
came out of an organic editable process
we realized back in 2007 that men's
fashion is a struggling hard world guys
just starting out doing it sometimes out
of their apartment a lot of times these
guys already have all the talent they
just need a little bit more of a
spotlight I'm very proud of the dozens
of designers that we've supported over
the years they're all still in business
and doing well we were there for the
first one when it was just called six
best new designers in America the
picture that came out of that first
nomination is above the door when you
come to our office it's such an
incredible honor and they're pretty much
double their business as an American
menswear designer
it's totally flattering and it's
invaluable I've always been incredibly
grateful for the support that they've
given us I was a really special moment
being named best new designer for me I
was so nervous you know I got a phone
call from Jim Moore and I still think
back to it and even being in the
business as long as I have been I was
completely nervous as if I just started
you know fresh I want to have four
strongest looks possible I got the call
from mr. Moore and you know it was like
being a kid I don't know we'll see you
on I think that I look cool with his
hair Jim Moore called me I'll never
forget that blew me away
blew me away Daleks gray someone
actually dropped the phone you know
someone cried we keep it as a drumroll
they don't really know they're being
called for that reason you know Jim
Moore I mean he's like The Godfather of
menswear like he really made menswear
what it is he try to act professional
but your blood starts racing
are you kidding me us our little brand
it's probably all said and done in an
hour probably one of the most exciting
hours of my entire year when you walk
don't bend your knees over the years we
decided that wouldn't it be great to
somehow help them with their retail
presence so we could put these name
brands in everybody's backyard
the four designers this year are each
doing six to twelve pieces for the gap
and those pieces are based on a
presentation that they made to the gap
and to us first we have an waar rob
Garcia's collection part of the edgiest
of all the designers that we've ever
featured the leather hoodie the clothes
have an incredible construction at a
workmanship to them dialed in some
really cool chain mountains life is a
little bit different I'm in the GQ
office it's an amazing story John Eliot
because he really didn't see himself
until a couple years ago as a fashion
designer your hand in there it's just
that is by far our best seller he hit us
immediately as being someone who was not
only savvy and street smart but also had
an incredible design aesthetic
by the way we have a little surprise
gift for you yeah Ed McMahon like
$10,000 check are you kidding
that's for you thank you that's amazing
Daniel is a mild-mannered Tiger he does
a slim suit that kind of solves every
guy's problem we try to design clothes
for the guy who does really interesting
things in his life I was a little
nervous
nice to see you been doing this a while
but that was like big time this is a
pair of original and me Makaha drowners
that sparked the whole thing launched mu
2 years ago John Moore was the perfect
archaeologist designer to find those
pair of shorts because he went deep into
the surfing culture I would love to
bring the tape detail into the nylon
piece because we've never done that
before you have no idea how like far
this will go I feel that this is a real
partnership which is killer figuring out
how to combine the worlds of gapping on
the walk it seems so extreme but yet
there's so many ways to like mesh
together I think we'll come up with
something really really amazing we're
two brands that are really about
creating essential timeless pieces for a
guy but that's the thing that the gap is
really embracing and that's the thing
that we really want to get out there the
fact that a guy can wear a leather
hoodie four men wore a suit from
Brooklyn tailors or a striped t-shirt
for Emmy or a cool pair of jogging pants
from John Elliott what makes this
collection even more exciting is that
the gap now just sees this thing and
they're like we should take this Japan
we stick to China which they do Europe
so these American designers are now
getting their first shot on a Koloa
basis that's huge for them that makes
you want to rise to the occasion and be
better than you ever have been before
that's what we're gonna do we're gonna
work as hard as we can to make sure that
we really do something that's special